[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
KATE VOEGELE: Thanks, you guys.
It's so fun to be here.
I was saying, this is way more
legit than a lot of the music
venues that I play.
You guys have
matcha lattes here.
They don't have that at
all the music venues.
This is really cool, actually.
I'm from Cleveland,
so not far away.
AUDIENCE: Ohio!
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah, right?
I know it's kind of a
controversial thing.
I'm playing tonight in the
city, and I'm kind of like--
I was telling
Jason, I always try
to tell a joke, kind of,
about the thing where
I'm from Buckeye Nation.
It never quite lands, so I'm
not sure how to approach it.
But no it's awesome.
It's so great to be here.
I love the Midwest and
stuff, so thank you
guys for staying on a Friday
when the weather is psycho
and hanging out.
I want to play you guys my new
single, which I put out just
about a month ago.
And this is kind of a song
about taking your power back
when somebody has messed
with you or whatever,
manipulated you and
stuff like that.
So I'd written a lot of
sad, bummed out songs
about things like
this, but I figured
that it was kind of time to
do something a little bit
different, from
a little bit more
of a angle that
takes back the power.
This is a very acoustic version.
The actual track is
a lot more produced.
It's called "Shoot This Arrow."
[MUSIC - KATE VOEGELE, "SHOOT
THIS ARROW"]
[APPLAUSE]
JASON ANDREAS: Well
thank you, Kate,
thank you so much for
playing that song for us.
We'll talk about
the song and some
of its meaning in a little bit,
but thank you for stopping in.
I know you said on
the intro to the song,
it is a snowy, wintry
day here in Ann Arbor,
so thank you for
braving your tour bus.
You guys were in Pittsburgh last
night, on to Chicago tomorrow.
So thank you, truly, for
stopping in to Ann Arbor
and playing for us.
And you play at the
Blind Pig tonight.
You've been on tour
now for a little while.
You took a little
hiatus over the holidays
when you released the
single, and you've
been out on the
road in January now,
and you were basically
touring all of last year
and a bit of 2016
around your new album.
Let's start there
since you're touring.
You're here on the tour.
Can you tell us a little bit
about the tour, how it's going,
kind of what the
focus of the tour
and kind of the inspiration
that's been around it?
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah, absolutely.
It's been great.
It's been really fun to be on
the road playing some new music
and playing some
of these cities.
I've been to probably just
about every major city in the US
on tour since I've been--
touring is a main part of
my job for a decade or so,
which is crazy to say out loud.
But it's been really fun.
We had such a great
couple of years,
because I had never
really realized
how far reaching my music was.
And so I was in
Australia last month,
I was in Europe in
spring and the UK,
and playing all over
the US, and now kind
of looking to book something
in Asia for next year.
So it's been really exciting
and really fun to bring
the songs to the fans.
The vibe of this tour
has been exactly sort
of what you guys just saw.
It's been super just an
intimate, acoustic experience
where I can feel
like I'm just having
some hang time with my
fans, which is really
important to me, you know?
I'm a Midwest girl.
I'm from Ohio.
It's kind of in my
personality, and I
wanted to take that and
bring that to this tour
more than I have
with other tours.
And so it's been really cool
JASON ANDREAS: That's awesome.
And you're playing with
Tyler Hilton, too, so--
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: --for those
of you guys that know,
Tyler was also a
"One Tree Hill" alum.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: So
you guys, obviously,
have a really strong dynamic.
You have a good history.
How do you guys work
so well together?
And you were-- you've
done the Australian tour
and the European tour with him.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: You guys
have a pretty cool kind
of stage presence together,
and you play a lot on stage
together.
Tell us about kind of
why you and Tyler vibe
so well together.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah, for sure.
We started with a
UK tour in 2015,
and it's cool,
because both of us
played our music on the
show "One Tree Hill,"
but we never worked
together on the same season
or the same episode let alone.
And so we thought
this might be kind
of fun for fans who know
both of us from the show
but never saw us
interact on the show.
And so it's almost like--
it feels like a bonus
feature or something
on like a DVD collection.
Even though, obviously,
we're ourselves and not
our characters,
it's a cool thing,
and it's exciting
for fans to see.
And then halfway
through that first tour,
we started inviting each other
up during our respective sets
to sing harmonies and play.
And we were like, we should
just do this together, and be
on stage together
the whole time,
and make it kind of
a songwriters round.
If anybody's been to Nashville
or maybe watched the show
"Nashville," that's a big
thing in the songwriting world,
is kind of hanging a round
where you and I would
be up here with guitars and we'd
switch on and off playing songs
and--
JASON ANDREAS: That
probably wouldn't go so well
if it was you and I, though.
I don't know what I'm doing.
KATE VOEGELE: You could try.
You never know.
JASON ANDREAS: I'll
karaoke with you.
KATE VOEGELE: You have
guitars, you know.
You've got the equipment.
But it's cool, and the
dynamic is really unique.
We play off of each
other really well.
Tyler and I have had
extremely parallel careers.
It's really funny,
kind of like we're just
guy-girl versions of each other
in some ways with our music.
And so it's really been a
super congruent way to kind
of bring this new angle
to our music, to our fans,
and it's been fun
to do it together.
JASON ANDREAS: That's awesome.
I'm going to hit
the show tonight,
so I'm very psyched about that.
We talked about this
a little bit earlier,
too, so I don't know if
a lot of you guys know.
Another "One Tree Hill"
alum, Jana Kramer,
is from Rochester Hill, so
she's just right up the road.
She took a similar
path to you guys
as well, in terms of
acting into music,
and she's found some
great success, too.
So would you guys ever consider
bringing Jana with you guys?
KATE VOEGELE: Totally.
JASON ANDREAS: So Jana,
Tyler, Kate on the same tour.
Can we do that?
KATE VOEGELE: Oh,
I would love that.
Yeah, we would
totally love that.
No, she's great, and
she's been killing it.
It's really cool to see, because
I did work with her a lot
on the show.
We filmed a lot of
scenes together.
And so it's been really
fun to kind of see
how everybody's career and
life has sort of progressed
since then.
But, yeah, I'm totally,
like, I'm always
excited to collaborate with
other musicians, especially
when they're friends.
So, yeah that would be awesome.
JASON ANDREAS: Did she do
"Dancing with the Stars."?
KATE VOEGELE: I think she did.
She was really good.
JASON ANDREAS: Can
we get you on that?
Would you do that?
Would you-- are you a
dancer or just a singer?
KATE VOEGELE: I was a
dancer in high school.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah?
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
You know, I've thought about it.
I would have to really,
seriously consider it, just
because I would be so afraid
that I would wipe out and break
my leg in front of people.
Because that's so
much something that
would happen to me on
national television.
JASON ANDREAS: And that
stuff's intense, too.
Like the--
KATE VOEGELE: Oh,
it's, like, so intense.
JASON ANDREAS: --the stuff that
they go through on that show
is incredible.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah.
KATE VOEGELE: It's
really intense.
I probably would do it.
I would just have to really--
I would be so--
I would be super intense
about practicing.
It would like-- oh my god,
I would be so terrified.
Yeah.
I don't know, but I was
really-- she killed it.
I was super impressed.
JASON ANDREAS: She did well.
Yeah.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah, I
was cheering for her.
JASON ANDREAS: Well
that's our plug.
Let's get Kate on
"Dancing with the Stars."
Let's see if we can
make that happen.
So the tour that we
were just talking about,
you're just doing like a
two-week stint right now,
and you only have a few more
dates here before you're done,
end of January.
That gives you basically
the rest of 2018.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: What
are you looking at?
Like what's-- you released
"Shoot This Arrow"
plus another song during
the summertime of last year,
so that's two songs since
your "Canyonlands" album.
New album, any
additional acting?
What's on the horizon for you?
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah,
I'm definitely
excited to do some
more touring this year.
I'm hoping to go back to Europe
and the UK in the summer.
And then definitely going
to try to do more stateside
stuff when it's warm.
Like, for the last
few years we've
been doing these tours
around the holidays
and then after the
holidays in New York
and Boston and the Midwest.
And I love this
part of the country.
It's where I'm from,
it's great, it's amazing.
But I'm like, perhaps we should
take a look at September.
So we're definitely hoping to
do some more shows when it's not
the bomb cycle or whatever
they're calling this storm
thing outside.
In addition to the touring,
I have a bunch of new music
that is--
JASON ANDREAS: Awesome.
KATE VOEGELE: --on the
horizon to come out
alongside "Shoot This Arrow."
And I'm not quite
sure what it's going
to be yet, if it's going
to be an EP or an LP
or singles or a vinyl.
I have kind of a lot
of things in the works,
but I've been working with
the same producer on all
of this music, and I'm
really excited about it.
So that's going to
be a big focus for me
this year, is putting
new music out,
and then really
focusing on creating
a lot of cool
multimedia around it.
I'm really leaning in more
to the artistic side of what
I do creatively.
I was an art school kid
before I signed a record deal
and ended up dropping
out to go on the road,
and started working on
the TV show about a year
later and stuff.
So I really want to bring
that back in and kind of
take an unconventional
approach to my next project.
And I'm really
excited about that,
because it seems like there's
so many interesting ways
that you can share music
with your fans now.
JASON ANDREAS: Sure.
KATE VOEGELE:
People experience it
so differently than they
did when I first got signed.
So I'm really excited to
explore what that looks like.
JASON ANDREAS: You
mentioned a minute ago, too,
potentially putting
something out on vinyl.
None of your music is on
vinyl right now, is there?
KATE VOEGELE: Not yet.
JASON ANDREAS: Is there
a reason for that?
Is there a different process of
putting something and pressing
it out on vinyl?
KATE VOEGELE: Well, yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: Is it a longer,
more difficult process?
KATE VOEGELE: It takes forever.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah?
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah,
it's really intense,
and I really wanted to do
it with my last record,
this record called "Canyonlands"
that I put out in 2016,
because it really was
kind of my tribute
to a lot of the influences that
I grew up on, like '70s stuff.
And so it really felt like
the right record to do vinyl,
but it was like an eight
month lead time or something.
Because it's-- what's happening
is it's becoming so popular,
and every band, every
artist wants to do it.
And these vinyl
pressing places are not
equipped to handle
all of this stuff.
JASON ANDREAS: Right.
KATE VOEGELE: And it's
an old school technology.
It takes forever.
So, I never got around to it.
But of course now I'm like,
well, if I had done it,
then I would have it by now.
So, you know, I'm thinking
that I'll definitely
try it with at least one album,
or at least this new project
for sure.
JASON ANDREAS: Cool.
That's awesome.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: You talked
about some of your inspiration
just a minute ago.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: I
think you mentioned
'70s southern California
kind of folk rock.
Can you talk a
little bit about--
this is kind of a
combination question.
So one, going all the way back
to how you kind of developed
your passion and desire
to be a musician,
and then what some of
those inspirations looked
like around the development of
who you became as a musician
eventually?
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah, absolutely.
I was probably the
most inspired to start
writing songs and
making music by my dad,
because he is an awesome guitar
player, a great songwriter,
and I grew up watching
him play coffeehouses
around Ohio and stuff.
And I always thought
it was so cool.
And so he bought
me my first guitar
when I was really little.
I kind of messed around with it,
I learned a couple of chords.
And then once I
got a little older
and started really kind of
expanding my taste in music,
and not just kind of listening
to whatever my parents were
listening to, it's like I had
this foundation of my parents
music that was like Carole
King, James Taylor, Clapton,
and the Beatles,
Michael Jackson.
And then I also had--
I was a kid in the '90s, so it
was like NSYNC, Britney Spears,
Christina, like all this
super poppy '90s stuff.
And then there was like
Nirvana thrown in there
or whatever, you know.
My mom probably didn't want
me to have that cassette tape,
but I did and I was
like, this is dope.
And so it was like this mash
up of all of this stuff.
And I think that that's
kind of been reflected
in the different ways that
my songwriting has manifested
itself on different projects.
That "Canyonlands"
album is super inspired
by some of that '70s stuff, and
the Jackson Browns and Linda
Ronstadts.
And then some of this
new stuff I've been doing
is leaning in a little
bit more to kind
of taking that songwriting
approach and mixing it
with some of the pop
sounds and some of the more
kind of modern stuff.
And so it's been really
fun to sort of see
how all those different
influences can sort of show up
in different aspects of your
music and different projects.
JASON ANDREAS: And you've
done a couple of albums
over the past 10 years.
How has your style
changed, right?
So from your first
album to "Canyonlands"
and now what's
coming out, you've
had a lot of similarities
in your music.
Some of the songs you
can definitely tell
are Kate Voegele
songs, but you also
have come up with a lot of
different things as well.
Like "Shoot This
Arrow," for example,
has a totally different
sound from a lot
of the other stuff you've done.
How has your music kind of
matured over the past 10 years?
What's that process
look like for you?
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah,
it's definitely been
really cool to see how it--
what things are constant
and then what things change.
And I think one of
the main things that's
changed from a
writing perspective
is I'm so much more comfortable
with being vulnerable
now, and super dead
honest about things.
Whereas when I
was in high school
and I started writing
some of the songs that
made it onto my first album--
I was only like 18
when that came out--
I was writing these songs,
and I'm so proud of them
and I love them, but
I was trying really
hard to make sure
nobody could figure out
who I was writing about.
Because I was an introverted
kid and it was high school--
it was kind of a
small high school.
I didn't want people
to know, oh, she's
writing about that guy that
she went to the dance with,
but then they had that fight.
And I was super closed off,
close to the vest with it.
And every album if you kind
of listen to the writing,
you can hear it get more and
more open and vulnerable.
I really discovered what's
so great about great songs,
is when they're just
incredibly vulnerable.
Like any great
piece of art, right?
A film or a show or whatever.
When people are just
being inherently human
and you can relate
to it that's what
really makes it incredible.
So I've really learned how to
be more kind of straight up
and less afraid to kind of make
a statement that maybe somebody
is going to take this wrong.
I've really just gone for it.
And especially with
this new stuff.
"Shoot This Arrow" pretty
clearly, you know, there's
some aspects of that
song that are way more
honest than I've ever been.
So there's that.
And then the sounds.
You know, I think I've played--
I've been a little bit
more adventurous sonically,
what types of sounds I
surround the song with.
And that's been really,
really fun, too.
JASON ANDREAS: Cool.
Again back to
"Shoot This Arrow,"
because I wanted to make
sure we had a little time
to talk about that.
We chatted a little
bit beforehand.
There's a lot of
meaning, there's
some social meaning behind the
song, and it's personal for you
as well.
Feel free to talk about
it how deeply you want,
but I just wanted to
kind of ask if you
want to share a little bit
about where that song came from
and what the inspiration
was behind it, what
some of the meaning is
behind some of the lyrics,
and kind of dig into
that a little bit more.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah, absolutely.
It's a song that I had wanted
to write for a long time,
and finally kind of found the
right co-writer, producer.
We'd been writing a lot of stuff
together for the past year.
We were working together--
I think it was Halloween or
something-- and I was like,
let's do something
with a dark vibe.
And I had this voice note on my
phone called "Shoot This Arrow"
and it was kind of the
chorus of that song.
And really, it was crazy because
the song's inspiration came
from a lot of different places.
But a couple of
weeks after we wrote
this song, a friend of mine
who was a writer on the show
that I worked on took to
Twitter and kind of talked
about some issues that she
had with our show runner,
and it turned into
something that all
of the women from the
cast kind of teamed up
and we all decided
to kind of write
a collective statement about
our collective experience
with sexual harassment and
some pretty tough stuff
while we were on the show.
It was kind of an
open secret, something
that we had all kind
of walked on eggshells
and skirted around.
And no one really ever
thought the day would come
when we talk publicly about it.
So it was an amazing
coincidence, totally wild,
that this kind of happened
right after I had just
written the song.
So I felt really compelled
to share a snippet of it,
as I usually do when
I write new music.
I'll share snippets all
the time to kind of gauge
how the fans feel about it.
And it went crazy.
I mean, people
went totally nuts,
and the response
was really touching.
It was really cool to see
that people related to it.
I think I felt like, OK, well
this feels like something
that we should probably put
out sooner rather than later.
And so it ended up coming
out a couple of weeks later.
It was really cool, because I'd
been wanting to kind of kick
start this next
project and it just
felt like one of those genuine
things where I was like,
I can't really ignore
this opportunity
to sort of share something
that's important to me.
And I don't care if I have
to give this away for free.
I just want people
to be able to--
I mean, this is kind of my
goal with all of my music,
but I want people to be
able to connect, you know?
So that's been
extremely powerful.
And, you know, the
thing that I think
is the bigger
point of the song--
obviously I had my own
specific experiences
that inspired me to write it.
But to me "Shoot This
Arrow" is not only kind of
referring to speak
your truth and say
what you need to say even
if you're afraid to say it
or someone's trying to
get you to be quiet.
But it's also about
being yourself and doing
what you believe in, standing
up for what you believe in,
sharing your art despite people
who maybe try to discourage you
or silence you.
So it's not just
limited to oh it
has to be this #MeToo movement.
There are a lot of ways.
I think that that
song-- really for me,
was the moment that
I put that out, I
realized how much of my own
power I had been giving up.
Not just in that circumstance,
but in my career.
It helped me really get out of
the passenger seat of my career
and be like, oh, now I feel
like I can really take control
and take the power back.
It was pretty cool to have that.
JASON ANDREAS: What's
the reception been?
I know you teased some
of it to your fans,
but now that it's out in full,
what's the reception been
with your fans?
How about when you play it live?
Has it been positive
around the board?
Like are people
coming up to you--
I know you do a lot of meet
and greets with fans and things
like that.
Has there been a good
kind of feel for it?
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah,
it's been unbelievable,
way beyond anything I
could have imagined.
It's so cool to
see guys, girls--
across the board, I think--
like I said, from a
general standpoint,
being able to really
believe that you're worthy
and take control of your
life and your career
and understand that
nobody's going to ever care
about what it is you're
doing as much as you are,
and you have to drive the ship.
Seeing the fact that
the song has really
helped people who
were struggling
with a lot of the
things I was struggling
with is the coolest
thing in the world.
It's literally my
favorite part of my job,
is to meet somebody who's like,
wow I was having a bad day
and I heard this, and it doesn't
fix it but it makes it better.
It helps people
feel like, oh I'm
not the only one who
is out floating here
in this weird
circumstance, or having
this horrible internal
struggle or whatever.
Everybody's been there.
The reception has been amazing.
The fans have been so
supportive and really cool.
And it's really gratifying.
I'm on this big
group text message
with all of my girlfriends from
the TV show, all the actors,
the girls on the
crew, the writers.
And it's like the
camaraderie that
has come from us all kind
of stepping forward and just
being honest about something
and sharing our experience
so that maybe other people
will feel compelled,
like they don't have to
be quiet about something
and they can stand
up for themselves,
has been extremely cool.
And the fans have been so--
they've been a
huge part of that.
So it's pretty powerful.
JASON ANDREAS: And music
is such a powerful platform
for sharing things like
that as well, right?
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah, yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: You
can write about it,
you can read about it,
but music kind of puts it
into a whole different
kind of ecosystem
where it helps folks kind of
cope in a completely different
way, or brings people together
in a completely different way.
So I feel like it's just
such a powerful platform
to share a message like that--
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah, I feel
grateful to be able to do that,
for sure.
JASON ANDREAS: That's awesome.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: You
mentioned a minute ago, too,
as you were talking about
going through the process
of releasing this song--
and I follow you on a couple
of different social media
channels.
I think you do this
really cool thing
and I haven't seen it done by
a lot of artists, where you
actually, as you're going
through the creative process,
you share a lot with your fans.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: You'll
sit down on Facebook Live
or you'll sit down on
Instagram and you'll
play a little bit
of a song you're
thinking about releasing.
And it's really interesting
to kind of watch
the comments that come through.
Can you talk about how
you use technology?
You've really
adjusted, obviously--
you talked about vinyl a minute
ago, going very old school
and then using the platform of
technology to connect with fans
and share your music.
You've gone from kind of both
sides in one conversation.
Talk about the
technology side and how
you've been able to
utilize that to stay
connected with your
very strong fan base.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah,
that's a great question.
Actually it's really cool,
because what really ignited
my interest in using technology
to connect to my fans
was my first record deal
was with Myspace records.
Which is kind of like
making me feel like TBT.
But--
JASON ANDREAS: Do you guys
all know what Myspace is?
KATE VOEGELE: I know, people
are like-- some of these people
are like, I don't
know what that is.
But you know it was--
I was really young, and it
was the biggest social network
platform out there
at that point.
It was kind of the only
social network platform.
And Tom Anderson who founded
it was a huge music fan,
and so he decided he
wanted a record label.
And he actually hit
me up through Myspace
and asked me if I was signed--
JASON ANDREAS: The Tom.
KATE VOEGELE: --and
was like, want
to come out to Santa Monica
and showcase for my label?
And I was like, first of
all, this is a real guy.
That's crazy.
And second of all, I love that
he's using his social media
platform to contact people.
Like, he's the
true early adopter.
It was amazing.
So that record deal was
life changing for me,
because I really learned
just how much reach
that platform afforded me.
And so I started
using Myspace, and I
started trying to figure
out, OK, well what
artists are similar to me?
Who likes Ingrid Michaelson?
OK, well, maybe that they
would want to come to my show.
And things like that and kind
of the connectivity of just how
quickly you could
reach somebody who
was a potential fan or already
a fan started to really sink in.
So now that we have so many
unbelievable means to interact
with our fan base
as creatives, that's
what gets me super excited
about the Facebook Lives
and about the
Instagram, and we live
stream our shows sometimes.
The stories, I try
to really share
sort of what it's like
being on the road.
I mean none of this
stuff was anything
I was able to do five
years ago or whatever.
And so it's something
that I think is really--
we're at a really fun,
unprecedented time in music
and the creative entertainment
world in general,
where you have people excited
about vinyl and even cassette
tapes.
With all these shows
kind of featuring things
about cassette tapes,
"Stranger Things," like people
are all about nostalgia.
Especially like
our fans love it.
We take Polaroids at the end of
our shows and people go crazy.
They love the Polaroids.
But then they're also
on these platforms
and they're using
Instagram stories,
and they're tuning in live.
And it's the coolest
convergence of things.
And I think if we can
kind of like use those two
kind of the very old school
stuff and sort of like play
off of what's great about that.
But then also bring it
into this new space,
where you have this amazing
ability to reach people just
with something in your pocket.
I think that is really,
really exciting.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah, it's been
such a kind of crazy past 15
years, where you had the
music industry completely
melting down when
Napster came out,
that this was going to
ruin the music world.
Which a lot of people
thought was the case.
And technology kind of
got bunched into that,
because obviously
this was a technology.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: And
it became, all right,
technology's going to
ruin the music industry.
It's going to take money
away from the musicians
and artists and all of the
process that goes along
with that.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: And
so there was a lot
of people on one side
of the fence saying
this is the worst thing ever.
But there was a lot of
people on the other side
of the fence saying, hey,
how can we embrace this?
How can we actually run with
it and use it as a connector
with out fans, and to
change the way we do music?
And of course, that cycled back.
Like you said,
now vinyl is huge.
Now there's all this nostalgia
around like old formats.
So we've kind of gone through
the roughest patch I think.
I know there's still challenges
with technology, but--
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: --it's
always awesome to see
a musician, an artist,
who really kind of grasps
technology and is able to
kind of make it their own.
So that's awesome.
KATE VOEGELE: Thanks.
JASON ANDREAS: Can
you talk a little bit
about outside, then, of music?
You're a very creative
person, you're
very artistic as we
were discussing earlier.
Can you talk a little bit
about some of the things
that you like to do outside of--
when you're home
from touring, when
you get off the tour
in a couple of weeks,
what you're working on.
What are some of the
other creative outlets
that you like to focus on?
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah, absolutely.
I actually just
kind of started--
I sort of soft launched this
lifestyle company called We
The Dreamers that I've been
working on for a long time.
And it's named after a song
from a few records ago.
And I noticed people were coming
to shows with shirts and phone
cases where they had
written, We The Dreamers
and I thought, oh
wow, that's cool.
I should, you know, I should
use that for something.
And so it's been really fun,
because for me as an art kid
and someone who
loves making stuff--
I love great design.
I'm like so interested in
anything that has to do with--
like I'm going crazy looking
at the Google offices.
It's so awesome in here.
I'm like, oh my god, that
light fixture is amazing.
Like all this stuff that
drives my husband nuts
that I care about.
But, you know, it's--
We The Dreamers has become
this really cool kind of space
for me to on one hand, share
content that I'm interested in.
My outfits, my
clothes, what I wear
onstage or off
stage, and my travel
photos, because
I love to travel.
I travel a lot for work,
and so I do tour diaries.
But I also love to travel.
My husband and I, we'll
pick up and go to Barcelona
and buy a ticket and
go the next week.
You know, like, we do a
lot of stuff like that.
So it's kind of a fun space
for people to get to know me,
but also for me to share cool
photography, and just things
that I'm into at the moment
whether it's with decor
or whatever.
And then also it's
got an e-commerce side
where I started designing
these printed leggings,
kind of a yoga pants type thing,
based on prints that I made,
patterns that I made out
of my watercolor paintings.
I've always been a painter.
I've always had a painting
set up on the road.
When I'm on a tour bus, I take
the back lounge of the bus
and there's canvas everywhere
and paint everywhere.
And that's kind of
my creative outlet
when I'm stuck with
writer's block or whatever.
Painting and
designing really helps
me have a new
creative perspective.
And so I wanted to take
that and create something
that could be more
of a lifestyle thing,
instead of just
paintings themselves.
It's been really fun and really
exciting to start developing
that, and it is
something that I'm really
excited to fold into what
I'm doing with this new music
this year.
Because I've always
designed my album covers,
my t-shirts, and I've done a
bunch of brush letter lyric
print type things.
So it's a big part of
who I am as a musician,
but it's also just a huge
part of who I am as a person.
So I'm excited to kind
of have that outlet.
And, I think, just give
my fans an opportunity
to interact with sort
of my creative vision
in a way that's outside
of just buying a CD
or coming to a show.
JASON ANDREAS: Sure,
and you mentioned
you get a lot of your creative
vision from travel, too.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: What's,
like, in all of the touring
that you've done and the
opportunity to travel
that you've had with
your career, what's
your favorite spot?
I hate when people
ask me this question,
so I just totally bit
the bullet on this one,
because it's hard to pick
just one, I know, right?
So it's 15 things and it
turns into a conversation.
But do you have
a favorite memory
from being on the road or
touring or anything like that
where you were like this is
just literally the coolest place
I've ever been?
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: I don't know If
we'll ever be able to top this.
What's that for you?
KATE VOEGELE: There
have been so many.
I think for me, playing
my first show in Paris
and having it sell out, and that
was my first time ever going
to Paris, was totally surreal.
It was so wild.
Because I've always
wanted to go there,
and I had no idea that there
were so many fans there
and that it would sell
out when I had never been.
And so that was pretty
epic, and it's pretty cool
that we've continued to go
back and play shows there year
after year.
And Sydney this past
December was an incredible.
I mean, all of Australia
was incredible,
but that city was wild.
I've always wanted to
go there and our show
sold out so quickly we had add
another one like right away.
And so I think
when I'm somewhere
kind of that is a
destination that I've always
wanted to go to
anyways, and then I
realize that, wow, there's
people who know my music here
you know?
And not only do
they know my music,
but they want to come to a
show and I've never been here
before, that is a crazy feeling.
So it's always the first
time going somewhere
that feels far flung
for a kid from Ohio,
the first time going
there to sell out of show
is the craziest experience ever.
So I'm so grateful for
that and so grateful
for the fans, that they
are patient with us,
because sometimes it takes
forever for us to get over
to Australia.
And so, yeah, it's pretty cool.
The travel aspect
of it is definitely
my favorite part of the job.
JASON ANDREAS: That's awesome,
and you mentioned potentially
doing an Asia tour,
so if you want
to talk about far flung
from Cleveland, Ohio.
That's a very different
place in the world so,
it would be very cool.
KATE VOEGELE: Oh,
I'm so excited, yeah.
I really hope we
can make it happen.
It's definitely-- yeah.
That would be, this would be
the time of year to kind of be
doing the kind of like
South Asia, Australia thing,
and then we'll come
here in the fall.
I'm like, we just need to
do some better planning.
Australia was
amazing in December.
It was like 80 degrees,
we went to the beach.
JASON ANDREAS: Perfect.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah, it
was pretty cool, so.
JASON ANDREAS: That's awesome.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: I wanted
to open up really quick,
just to see as we get a
little closer to the end.
Any questions that
you guys wanted
to ask from the
audience, ask Kate?
Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so,
you and I, we're
both from Bay Village, Ohio--
KATE VOEGELE: No way!
JASON ANDREAS: A fellow
Bay Village, Ohioan.
KATE VOEGELE: Wait.
Stop.
That's crazy.
AUDIENCE: We both went
to Bay Public Schools.
KATE VOEGELE: When
did you graduate?
AUDIENCE: 2012.
KATE VOEGELE: Oh my goodness.
OK, that's so crazy.
So you might have gone
to school with my sister?
Or, no, wait, my cousin.
Maybe my cousin
Paige [INAUDIBLE]??
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I know her.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah, OK.
I'm thinking my sister, it's
like no, my sister's too old.
No, OK.
JASON ANDREAS: Do we need
to get Paige's permission
to use her name on this video?
KATE VOEGELE: She'll probably
be super excited about it.
JASON ANDREAS: Hi, Paige.
How are you?
Hope you're doing well.
KATE VOEGELE:
That's so cool, man.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: My name's Abe.
KATE VOEGELE: OK, Abe.
JASON ANDREAS: Abe.
AUDIENCE: My question is how
did growing up in Bay Village
affect your songwriting?
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: Let me repeat the
question real quick, because we
don't have a mic out there.
So the question from Abe
was how did growing up
in Bay Village, which
I told you earlier, I
grew up not too far from there.
My mom's from Lorain, Ohio,
so very close down the road.
So how did growing up in a
community like Bay Village,
it's a smaller community
outside of Cleveland,
how did that affect your
career, your songwriting
and inspiration?
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah,
that's a great question.
It's an awesome little town.
It's like, you know, very,
just, quiet and suburban.
It's on the lake.
It was beautiful, like such
a beautiful place to grow up.
It's really got an amazing
sense of community,
too, which I think was
probably a big influence
for me starting out.
Especially in high
school and stuff
when everything is sort
of weird and everyone's
trying to figure
out who they are
and everyone's really
self-conscious and stuff.
So writing songs
for me was totally
an outlet to sort of just
figure out all of those things.
I think growing
up in a community
like Bay helped me to
feel a little bit more
at ease about playing my
first couple of shows,
because even though it was
just, like, my mom's friends
and like so some of
cousins and stuff,
knowing that people would
come out and like show up
and, you know, knowing
that probably even if it
was really bad, that people
would feel like, it was great.
You know?
It was really comforting, and I
probably didn't think about it
consciously at the time.
But I think having
a sense of community
is probably the most
important thing in order
to sort of nurture the
desire to be creative.
And that's the other
thing about Bay Schools
was art and music
was so emphasized.
Our programs were great.
We had incredible
teachers, and I really
credit a lot of
my music teachers,
especially the ones from
when I was really young,
who taught me about harmony
and, you know, solfege,
the do-re-mi stuff.
Stuff that I still use
in my songwriting today.
And it was so ingrained
in me as a young kid,
and I had a lot to do with how
much the arts were emphasized
in my hometown.
So I'm really grateful for that.
JASON ANDREAS: Do you get--
were you recently in
Cleveland for this tour?
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah,
we actually just
played there a couple days ago.
JASON ANDREAS: That's awesome.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah, it was cool.
JASON ANDREAS: Nice to get back
home after time away, right?
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah
JASON ANDREAS: So cool.
KATE VOEGELE: It
was so fun, yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: Any other
questions from the audience?
Oh, yeah.
Let's do two more, and
then we'll wrap from there.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I love your style.
KATE VOEGELE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Who makes your boots
and who makes your blazer?
KATE VOEGELE: Oh, nice, yeah.
So the blazer is from Zara, and
my boots are Jeffrey Campbell.
JASON ANDREAS: The
question was who
makes your fantastic outfit?
KATE VOEGELE: Oh, yeah, sorry.
JASON ANDREAS: Looks wonderful.
KATE VOEGELE: Thank you, thanks.
JASON ANDREAS: Looks great.
That's a good question.
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: I had a question.
So you've mentioned
a couple times now
that in order to
do what you love--
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --you got
out of your zone
in order to make that happen,
especially with the song,
you mentioned you had
to be OK with exposing
your vulnerabilities,
or you had to be
OK with signing a record deal,
or just kind of jumping off
with no [INAUDIBLE] there.
You just kind of went for it.
How do you get to
that particular point
and just decide to jump.
What made you say "Yes,
I'm ready to do that,
and let's just
see what happens?"
KATE VOEGELE: Yeah that's
such a great question.
Do you want me to
repeat sort of what--
JASON ANDREAS: Go ahead, yeah.
KATE VOEGELE: --he asked or--
So he kind of asked, you know,
how did you get to the point
where you were OK with
really taking the big step
where you had to get
out of your comfort zone
in order to do a lot of the
things that I've mentioned?
Sign a record deal,
leave college,
put out music that's really
honest and vulnerable.
And it's such a good
question, because honestly I
really am the opposite
of the personality
that you would expect to be
in the position that I'm in.
People that I went
to high school with
are were probably like,
Kate's kind of quiet
and hangs out in
the art room a lot.
I was not the type
of "look at me!
I love being in front of
people, in front of the camera!"
type thing.
So a lot of this job was
out of my comfort zone
from the get go.
I was so awkward in my
first shows and stuff,
because I was terrified to be
up in front of people and stuff.
And so ever since
then everything
that I've done in this
job has really pushed me.
It was really hard
for me at first,
but I started to
notice that I would--
to answer your question,
the way that I really
got up the courage to
take those big leaps
was by taking small ones and
sort of proving to myself
that OK, I lived through that.
It was fine.
I played that show.
It was awkward.
It's a rib cook-off.
No one's here.
It's raining.
I'm 15.
You know?
That's a real
thing that happened
to one of my first shows, was
like this rainy rib cook off
in Pittsburgh, and no one was
there because it was raining.
No one wants to cook ribs,
and no one knew who I was yet.
I was like a kid.
And my grandma came,
and I was really nice.
But just getting through that
was me proving to myself, OK.
I got up on stage, there was
no one there, it felt stupid,
but I'm alive and it's cool.
And I think every time that
I've gone and done something
that I've been nervous
to do, something awesome
has come out of it eventually,
even if it's not directly.
And so I learned pretty
early on that my personality
is one where I'm going to want
to, like, kind of pull away
from a lot of things
that are uncomfortable.
But I kind of have learned
that it's really always better
if I kind of force myself to
do the stuff that's scary.
There's actually a
book that I love--
it's cool if I, like,
mention a book, right?
JASON ANDREAS: Absolutely.
KATE VOEGELE: OK, cool.
It's by Steven Pressfield and
it's called "The War of Art."
I read it probably
at least once a year,
but if you're ever in a
spot where you're creative
and you feel like you feel
this resistance toward making
your art or putting it
out there or whatever,
it's such a good book.
And it's really just
kind of all talking
about that same principle.
It's just kind of like making
art for its own sake and kind
of being able to
get to the place
where you can feel like the
importance of sharing what it
is you're making is bigger
than the importance of exuding
whatever it is you want
people to think about you.
I had to get to a point
where I was like, OK.
And the same thing holds
true with some of this stuff
about just being honest.
Even if it's not the
most comfortable thing
to talk about, like the stuff
that's happened with my friends
and I on the show, and kind
of coming out and being honest
about all the stuff
that we went through.
It's not comfortable and
sometimes it's not fun,
and it's kind of scary.
And I was so nervous to play
that song the first couple
of times I did,
because I'd never
been honest about this stuff.
But it's like, you have
to put your own integrity
above your desire for people
to kind of always like you,
or above your need to be liked.
So that's kind of
one of those things
that I really had to learn,
because for sure, when
you're from the Midwest, it's
very benefit of the doubt.
Like, you apologize too much.
Everyone's so nice,
and it's just--
and I've worked with some
incredible people in my career.
So I feel so lucky that--
you know, it's few
and far between
that you feel like you're
in the opposite situation.
But, yeah, definitely it's
still really hard for me,
but getting out of
the comfort zone
is always where you find
the coolest opportunities.
That was a great question.
JASON ANDREAS: Well
thank you so much, Kate.
Thank you for coming in today.
You know, we realize there's
many different things
you could be doing today
versus coming into Google.
You've got a busy tour schedule.
So thank you so
much for coming in.
Thanks for sharing your energy.
Thanks for playing
a song with us.
Good luck at the show tonight,
and the rest of the tour.
You're always welcome
back at Google anytime.
So thank you so much.
Appreciate it.
KATE VOEGELE: Thank
you guys for having me.
[APPLAUSE]